sometimes we have to give you some
techniques so even though I'm going this
way we can go across the body so we'll
just say and that will end your punch we
can go here
but there's one
close up the other two
up to the shoulders
what about this inside out
this one inside out
um
wow
you paid them oh thanks you don't do
that to me don't ask me to repeat them I
was on a free flow
so that's what I wanted to do I want to
try to
stop yourself thinking
if something seems to be there that you
can choose
um even if I'm not making sense
you can see what I've just done
I programmed the techniques and then I
saw what come that I could do from that
technique
so I started on something
this is a technique that was a technique
there's the third one
outside
why did I pick cartoon angry because
when I done that I was actually going to
do a Sankey opinion but I saw his head
so I don't apply to Maggie
but my technical mind said I'll take
this and pin him now
I didn't follow my technical line
oh
so it may be hard for some of you to do
things that you think know what he's
talking about but I don't think my
limitations will allow that yet
then you'll have to just pose on
yourself
the part of that I hope you've noticed
without knowing it was every time I went
to him a little bit
not at any time did I say you come to me
because I'm the winner and you have to
lose every time what I said was let's
sort of join somebody
see what happens
even the dangerous one
I made sure I went in so deep
that you've got no chance of actually
hitting meals knife in me or whatever it
is in this thing if I had a guy like
that wide
at my foot
he doesn't need more children as well
real slow I met him
I went in
and then
I didn't feel that